Okay, market is
selling off hard today.
Uh we've kind of broken
previous lows of big kind of big levels
here. Um we had a huge sell-off kind of
yesterday pre-market and then yesterday
in the market. Um and today, you know,
we're kind of opening at the lows. So,
kind of two things can happen. Um ES and
Nasdaq look pretty much the exact same.
Is I want to think to look at is silver.
Uh this is a daily chart. Silver,
Bitcoin, um these are all having big
sell-offs today, especially the and and
oil here is still at a elevated price.
So, that's kind of
um [snorts]
market's been really funky right now. Uh
so, keep that in mind.
Big picture, looking at a 5-minute, um
you know, this is a huge sell-off. I
think if I had the fair value gap
indicator on a 15-minute chart, we would
have huge gaps right here.
Um
>> [snorts]
>> that being said, I think this this has a
total good potential to continue lower.
We're currently kind of in this
downtrend. Um what I would be interested
to see for a trade is
how this attempt to keep going lower
happens and then do we come up here and
and do a pullback like this or do we
come up here and kind of kiss the
attempt to go higher goodbye and push
lower. Um so, that would be kind of two
spots where I would look for a potential
long. Again, I would always be trying to
time that up with 15 minutes and 30
minutes after the market open.
Um
right now, we already had like a nice
push up here. This was pre-market and
then where it started to sell off and
looks like uh you know, we're we're
pushing the lows right now, seeing how
that will plays out. Nasdaq has already
made new lows.
And so,
you know, keeping that in mind here, uh
you know, what is this kind of it's
still in this downtrend, but it's is
that it accelerate to the downside and
is that going to fail? Um either way, I
think there's going to be volatility,
which is great for us in trading.
And so,
just got to stay focused and patient and
not FOMO over something cuz especially
in this kind of market, it's very easy
to
uh get trapped
in either direction, you know. I think
it's going to go one way and it flips on
you. Um so,
it's it's it's exciting cuz there's
potentially a lot of money to be made,
but also
honestly, you can lose a lot of money in
days like this. So, just got to stay
focused.
So, I'm just watching this and thinking
>> [cough and clears throat]
>> as well,
uh 5-minute, nice double bottom, nice
push up, but I'm we're coming to that
10:00, 30 minutes after the open. Are we
going to come up just to this zone
and continue the sell-off even even
though we've kind of broken this
downtrend. Um granted on a 5-minute,
like it could still be
we could still be holding it if you
think about, you know, like, okay, these
broke it barely. Like, it could break
this barely and then
um sell back off. Um
So, keeping that in mind, I'm still
seeing potential to go short.
>> [clears throat]
>> It It looks like it wants to fail.
It definitely looks like it wants to
fail. I don't want to get in yet though,
just because
um
it's kind of choppy. I want to see I
want to see it kind of either break
this, that would be ideal, and then do a
pullback.
So, I'm I'm just going to give it a few
more minutes.
Okay, that's a big fail breakout. The
scary thing is
it could
just
break out and I want to I want to see
Basically, I need to see the price
attempt to go higher a little bit, like
at least to right here somewhere would
be ideal.
Um it it has had a little bit of an
attempt to go higher here.
Um
it could just accelerate off of that. I
really would like to see an attempt to
go higher though.
Even if it's over one candlestick and
fail, just cuz that'll tell me
um cuz the scare is, okay, it's it's
flushing down a little bit, but it's
just going to break this and then
bottom, you know, like really like
there's a minor support right here that
we could just
uh bounce off of. And so,
I don't want to jump in long at this
support uh
with this volatile move. Okay, now that
looks really good. It's made a new low
here.
I want to see how this candle, the price
basically reacts to that. Okay, that's
really
strong to the downside. Again, I'm I
want to try and be patient here. I don't
want to chase this.
I really want to wait to see even again
like one bullish candlestick fail.
Um just cuz
uh you know, my stop will be somewhere
here. I just because of how this
market's acting, I need to see some kind
of pullback.
But I think I'm going to get short here
because I think if it makes a new low,
um
that is a great signal. It's showing
that
uh momentum, I think, potential to just
switch.
If it just comes here and and one tick
fills me and reverses,
uh frankly, that really sucks.
Uh but that's just kind of
that can happen.
I think this is a good enough signal to
get in short.
Uh
the Nasdaq not making a low yet is kind
of scary.
This is kind of
>> [snorts]
>> part of me feels like it's going to do
what I was waiting for, a pullback here
and then go lower. That would be the
better signal. And if it did that and
knocked me out, I would probably still
um
enter in again, frankly.
Uh I really hope it doesn't do that cuz
taking a a loss
and jumping in again
uh is hard. I don't really
I could try and move my stop up a little
bit here, but like honestly, I feel like
I'd have to move it up here, which would
uh increase my risk a lot. You know, I
would have to increase it to probably
like 2,000.
2,100, yeah, that's kind of a little too
large of size.
Um
God, this looks like it's just going to
bounce up though, which sucks.
Just breathing through it.
Big picture idea is there.
I think I'm just going to leave it.
Especially that it's reattempting a new
low right here, I think is good. I'm
just going to change my tool back to the
right size.
Still could go any direction.
Um
in terms of
risk [snorts] on the way down,
honestly, it could bounce anywhere.
That's kind of the scary part about uh
not having a a clean move up. You know,
it could run into resistance or support
here, here. Um but you know, I think the
overall potential is
still to the downside. Looks good. Um on
a 5-minute, honestly, that looks really
good on a 5-minute. You know, this is
like a clear it's had to move up, it's
come to this area.
It's made basically a This is a nice
failure to go higher.
So,
just kind of
got to let it play out now. Nasdaq,
thankfully,
uh
has made a new low here.
But again, you know, still not out of
the woods. I uh
Yeah, kind of just got to
I I have nothing to do right now. Um
until it I I think it has to spike It
needs to spike down here until maybe I
pull my stop down to here, reduce my
risk a little.
Um
I got to remember it it the market's
been choppy the whole day. It's been
kind of choppy and slow, so just got to
let it do its thing. I feel a little
more nervous than normal with this
trade. I think because the market's
my read doesn't feel as confident, but I
think it was still
um
a good enough signal to get in.
>> [sighs]
>> But you know, this is this is the scary
part where it feels like it could
there's potential for it to just rip
higher. If it breaks this, like if
Nasdaq breaks this clean, I think it's
going.
Same with the ES.
I still think it looks good like on a
5-minute.
Um I think the big picture looks good.
It's just
uh you know,
uh roller coaster of trading is hard
sometimes.
>> [snorts]
>> So, that is a really nice pullback.
That gives me confidence. NASDAQ has
broken
um
that upper area has had, so that feels
good.
>> [clears throat]
>> I just want to wait for this. I'll just
let you know, if you do want to get uh
this trading platform that I'm using,
it's called NinjaTrader. Um you can
start demo trading on it and
getting data for as little as $4.
Um which most other platforms cost $10,
$20
to get started. So, I I love it. I've
been using it for over 5 years at this
point.
I'll just leave a link for it in the
description below.
Uh I think at this point, I'm just going
to move my stop down to here at least.
Reduce some of that risk for sure. I'm
not going to move to break even yet. I
think it has to go down here
um or or do some kind of um pullback.
But right now, I think it looks great.
Um NASDAQ looks great
for reversal. I mean, this is a really
nice setup in terms of come up
and kind of make this kind of topping
pattern.
So,
ES looks good.
>> [clears throat]
>> Logically, I'm confident in the trade.
Emotionally,
I don't know. I've just uh
you know, sometimes it's just your your
emotions aren't
uh where they should be to be, you know,
calm, cool, and collected.
I don't know why. I I haven't been
sleeping well lately. I'm kind of sick,
so
maybe that doesn't that's not a I'm not
kind of top of my game right now
mentally, so
But at the end of the day, you know, I I
was patient. I entered in when the
signal was good. I pushed through the
nervousness. The the
the thing you have to do with trading is
even though I was nervous,
I didn't let it control my actions. I
didn't let that doubt stop me from
entering, you know. Once I really saw
the signal that confirmed it enough,
I took it.
So,
and then, you know,
with whatever happens with the trade, I
honestly I'm happy with the entry. I
mean, like
I think this looks insanely good on a
5-minute to push the lows
um and you know, potentially go lower.
So,
still not going to move break even. I
mean, I think this could easily have a
pullback here.
Um you know, retest the middle of this
candlestick. You could say there's maybe
a a downtrend like this. I don't quite
know. I'm going to clean my chart up
here a little bit.
Uh
Yeah, that's kind of where we're at
right now.
15-minute looks good. I mean, it's a
very clean on a 15-minute chart. This
shows it even better. It's just a very
clean like
retest of this, you know, market
bounces, breaks below, comes back and
and pushes lower. Basically, this is a
continuation trade, um but I'm entering
it as a reversal.
I'm looking for a reversal on the lower
trend, but the big picture is basically
a continuation. Um
That's kind of how I trade is is I'm I'm
trading with you know, you always need
to be going with a big picture trend.
And the big picture trend
gave me reason to look for a reversal
here.
Um
But I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily if
I if I thought the big picture to the
upside, I wouldn't take a uh uh
uh trade here because on a small time
frame, that's a continuation trade to me
versus a reversal.
The reversals like this, I feel like
give me high risk or or high reward. You
know, I'm shooting for two to three X
here where, you know, the risk here is
is one, you know, I'm risking $1,600 and
I could make I think pretty easily three
to $5,000. And obviously, if it gets
going and we break the lows here, which
is totally possible
with
this big trend down and how the market
is acting, we could totally uh keep
going lower.
And I could get uh more than that. I'm
still not going to go break even until
we have some kind of um better pullback.
Like we need to see I need to see
something like this.
And when it breaks kind of this low, I
would I would move my stop down to here.
If we're just going to slop down like
this,
I'll have a kind of a mental trailing
stop of okay, whenever it pulls back and
starts to
you know, change trend, then maybe I'll
I'll move a stop down here or or move it
to, you know, what makes sense. So, I'm
kind of in that fluid um management
right now.
I'm just going to move my target down a
little bit in case we do
get a you know, a big spike
candlestick like this.
NASDAQ looks great. Really, it's kind of
moved down and just making a
a bear flag
to continue lower. Big picture NASDAQ
I think looks great. Granted, we could
we could,
if you think about it, you know,
downtrend here, lower lows, lower highs,
and then this is a higher low. We could
come down here
and bounce
to start a bigger picture uptrend like
this. Um in terms of what that would
look like, if I just
pull up my Fibonacci tool. I forget
which button it is sometimes.
Um you know, a 50% pullback
of this swing, that's pretty standard
for a healthy pullback. So, right now
we're pretty much right there. Um so,
that's potential.
Um but
frankly, it's
same thing with the ES, but ES is like
pushing further. So, I think at this
point, I definitely move break even.
Um I don't I'm not going to let the
trade come back 2 and 1/2 thousand
dollars and and and give it even more.
Um I think at this point, I could say
we're probably in this downtrend right
here.
Um and so,
>> [clears throat]
>> I'm not at a point where I'm going to
get out any I'm going to close anything
out yet. Um
the NASDAQ has more to go. You could say
it's more bullish and it could just
bounce here.
Um
but
just letting it play out. I would love
to
get out at 3 X 5 K and you know,
realizing that okay, here are the lows
of the day.
We will potentially find uh support
there.
I will give it a little bit of wiggle
room, I think, with the idea that hey,
maybe we could break the lows
and let the bigger trend continue lower.
You know, cuz if we are coming down here
and making having this bigger trend in
play, well, we're probably going to make
a new low and continue lower
um before we have a larger pullback. But
again, I got to think about my trade and
risk reward and everything. And and once
it gets close to three X like
that's kind of when I like to uh start
to
manage it and get out because frankly,
getting three X on a trade is just a a
great win.
But if the market it stays in this
downtrend even through this level,
uh I'll just let it do its thing. And
you know, if it's just going to keep
printing me money, obviously, I want to
stay in.
I had a trade yesterday or the day
before that went down to basically two X
like this and then ripped back higher.
So, it would
it would suck to have that happen again,
but
I don't want to let that influence my
management here and try and say, oh
well, I don't want to have that, you
know, I don't want to have that happen
again. I don't want to miss out on some
money. I don't want to have another
break even trade. Um you know, every
trade is separate. I don't know how this
is going to play out. Obviously, it
doesn't feel good to see this happen
right now.
>> [cough and clears throat]
>> But
uh you know, I I want to manage this
trade how I see fit. How I see fit is
allowing it to have some kind of
pullback here.
And let it hopefully it retest these
lows before it really bounces.
Um or you know, have something like this
happen and I'll I'll get out here. And
you know, it's
if it just comes up here and rips like
it looks like it's doing,
uh that sucks. I mean, frankly, that
sucks. It just happened and that really,
really sucks.
Um because it looked really good. But I
also don't think there was a real reason
to jump out here until
uh this happened. And so,
that's difficult to deal with. I'm going
to have to go and, you know, um deal
with the emotions of
frustrating having a good trade, I think
have a good potential and just not work
out again. Again, it's I I'm way happier
to be break even.
But obviously, having a trade that goes
uh pretty much two X and then just rip
my head off to go break even like that
um with no real chance to get out, um
it sucks.
Cuz yesterday, if we look at this, just
to show you, I think it was actually
here 2 days ago.
I pretty much got in.
You know, I got in short, I think, here.
Went great two X.
Boom. Almost knocked me out and then
knocked me out here.
And then, you know, went a tiny bit
higher and then went down for the day.
So, that could totally happen today.
But obviously, I'm already out of the
trade and I'm not going to get in again.
And so,
it's a bummer, but
that's trading, you know? All you can do
is
focus on your entries, do good entries,
and and let the market do its thing, you
know? Sometimes it's going to do this,
and it's hard, but it happens.